hello everyone and welcome to game
number nine from the 1970 intra zonal
tournament department in Majorca
it's Bobby Fischer versus the bent
Larsen Bobby has the white pieces and
after five - in victories there were two
very very difficult games for Bobby
Fischer both of them he had a very tough
position but he was able to draw both of
them first one you know he just played
very nicely but the second one probably
because his opponent
Renato namaha didn't want to go for a
full point rather he was satisfied with
a draw now he faces a bent Larsen before
this game Bobby Fischer and went Lars
and they faced each other seven times
out of those seven times Bobby Fischer
won five games one game went to the bent
Larsen and one game was drawn and there
is a famous game between them it was
from the 1958 intra zonal tournament in
porto ROG you all remember the 1958
intra zonal tournament in Porto she was
the the tournament that you had you know
had have a very nice placement in order
to qualify for the 1959 candidates
tournament and their official face
Larson and Fischer play d4 Larsen
defended with the dragon Sicilian and
Fischer achieved a stunning victory so
in this game Fischer will also play
efore but instead of the dragon Sicilian
bent Larsen will play a different kind
of Sicilian but you know that game was
12 years prior to this game so surely
you know both of them have something to
show for and here before we before we
start this game
I have a very nice photo also from 1970
and while in 1970s Bobby Fischer was
taking this tournament and the entire
world by storm another chess player was
was you know slowly but surely becoming
a monster ready to someday conquered the
chess Olympus so he who is the person on
the right and for some additional points
you might also know who the person on
the left is so best of luck to everyone
would this photo challenge and we do
even have
photo of Fisher and Larson from the 1970
Palma de Majorca tournament so here it
is there they are
checking out I have no idea what that is
it appears to be some sort of a board
but it could also be a chess cake that
looks like a board so you know it could
really be anything it's very hard to
tell but there it is also a very nice
photo from 1970 now let's check out this
game like we said Fischer has the white
pieces and he opens with E 4 C 5 as we
said the Sicilian defense at night f3 d6
d4 see captor Sundy for night captor son
d4 and the Knight to f6 Knight to c3
Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 the source and
variation but Fischer played this move
so often that in a lot of chess
literature if you you know study just
from books the move will also be
required regarded as the Fischer's
weapon ecigs and Bishop to b3 I have a
book you know it's my friend Bobby
Fischer by the meteor bill it's aware
there are a lot of chosen games by Bobby
Fischer and whenever there's a Sicilian
being played there is the sauce and
variation and there is well this is the
position the game basically starts so a
lot a lot of difference games will start
from this position so before we continue
okay Bishop to e7 determining in
variation on the board Bishop to e3
we have castles Queen to e2 by Fischer
a6 and now a queenside castle Queen to
c7 we have g4 now Fischer of course
wants to attack on the Kings side nice
to d7 preparing to bring the knight over
to the Queen side the bishop from east 7
will also help out with the defense of
the King side h4 Fischer continued his
attack on the Kings side and now Knights
to c5 attacking the the very strong
piece that is the light square Bishop on
b3 g 5 and now b5 so this is a classic
case of opposite opposite castles
Larsson Castle then the Kings at Fisher
castles on the Queen side of course
Fischer wants to attack as soon as
possible on the Kings side whereas
Larson wants to attack as soon as
possible on the Queen side and here you
have a lot of moves to choose from for
example depending on
but what kind of a player you are you
can play h5 prepare g6 you can play King
b1 you can play f3 you know secure that
e4 pawn safety first and then continue
the game in the game Fischer played f3
and then the game continued as it did
but I always when when I have a position
like this I will always play g6 because
that is what Michael taught us you
always have to make your if your
opponent wants to attack you and you
want to attack your opponent you want to
make the attack happen as soon as
possible now it's a very interesting
move and I really check checked out what
would happen after H captures on g6 and
now of course h5 you want to grab every
temple available of course like cannot
but cannot allow whites to open up the H
file that would be game over
so after g5 you could pull this h6 and
the game continues probably what you
know if I had this game you know perhaps
I will play this maybe not but there is
also a very nice engine line that I
would like to show you just you know if
you will be in a similar situation maybe
you will use this simply you know as
pattern recognition maybe it will help
you in your own games
Bishop to d5 a beautiful move that now
creates a double attack against the
blacks knight on c6 and our black has to
decide whether he will play Bishop to b7
whether he will play Bishop to d7 and
then white will be able to continue with
his attack but if black for some reason
decides to capture this bishop then he
loses the game because the knight
captures on d5 now the Queen is under
attack and the Queen is the only piece
guarding the night here after the Queen
moves you can simply capture a knife
characters on c6 of course the Queen
cannot recapture because of Knight
captures on e7 after Bishop moves then
you capture capture and then you
continue with your attack and whatever
black does it's game over for example g6
Knight to f6 check and it's all over
Queen captures on f6 now comes h7 King
has to move Bishop before wins the Queen
it's game over
so of course g6 does not win the game
here but it's something
tal would surely play and it's something
that as as I know that he would play
that I would also play this in my games
as I like where the game you know goes
to but here Fischer would rather play f3
secure the position and only then figure
out what to do
Bishop to d7 now the knight on c6 is
guarded so the same idea will not apply
anymore Queen to g2 and now be for
attacking the knight on c3 Knight c2e2
and now comes Knight capture some b3 of
course a capture some b3 you cannot open
the C file a5 and here comes g6 now
Fischer doesn't want to prepare anymore
so now he does both g6 just to make his
attack happen a little bit faster F
characters on g6 h5 now attacking some
there is something to attack Knight
captures on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
the g5 of course Larsson doesn't want to
open up the H file Bishop captures on g5
Bishop captures on g5 with Czech Queen
captures on g5 and now h6 attacking
Fischer's Queen Queen to g4 and now
comes Luke to f7 rook a to g1 by Fischer
and now comes a 4b captors on 84 and now
comes a 5 and now this is pretty much
the critical moment in the game
Fischer doesn't really have all that
much to do here he has to play Knight to
f4 and after Bishop captures pawn
captures rook captures I mean it's it's
a better position for black Fischer
would really struggle to hold on in this
position so instead after this 'if i
move Fischer decided to play Knight to
e6 but this brings him a whole other set
of problems here
Queen to c4 was played now of course the
knight is under attack but also the
Queen could come to a 2 here Fischer
blocks b3 and he gives up his extra
piece not his extra piece but now Larson
will have the extra piece Queen captures
on e6 Queen captures and Bishop captures
so Fischer is down a piece but it's not
all that simple he's up upon and if he
could somehow eliminate the B pond and
he would have 3 connected pawns on the
Queen side and of those 3 2 would be
passed pawns so
it's not like completely simple to catch
this in rook to capture some d6 so
Fisher now grabs another pawn we have
rook to e8 and now look the b6 Fischer
goes for the b5 point
rook captures an f3 rook capture some
before and now comes Luke the c8
attacking the the backward C to pawn
king to be two as the bishop or rope
capture some b3 was a threat we have
looked to f2 now attacking the c2 pawn
and rope the c1 defending now and
although Fischer is still down a piece
he has three connected passed pawns on
the Queen side not an easy task to stop
Bishop to f7 we have a 5 now and now
instead of capturing on h5 immediately
there's always time for that first rook
to e8 not allowing Fischer to push the
passed pawn any further rope to b5
defending the pawn and only now rook
Bishop captures on h5 rook captures on
e5 Fischer grabs yet another pawn and
now comes Bishop to e2 rook the c5 we
have h 5 and now Larsen starts pushing
his own passed pawn ePHI and now comes a
bishop to f3 King to f3 now Fischer
wants to improve the position of his
King to start pushing those pawns h4 we
have King to d3 and now rook to e2 rope
to F 1 we have roped the 8 check King to
c3 and now Bishop to g4
of course the thread is rook captures on
c2 with check King before now the rook
is guarding it and now while Larsson
could capture the c2 point there's no
immediate reason to do this I mean you
can always do this so instead look to be
it checked first King moves and only now
h3 not even considering capturing the c2
pawn we have eastex by Fischer Bishop to
see to capturing a pawn now before we
have rook to e3 check King to be 2 and
Bishop to d3 now attacking the rook on
f1 rook to e1 and now Bishop to a6
stopping
Fischer pushing those passed pawns look
the c6 attacking the bishop rook
captures and before with check King to
see - and now Bishop to b7 rook has the
move we have looked to c3 rotary to
check King D 1 and here route
- was played and it was in this position
that Bobby Fischer for the first time in
this tournament in around nine resigned
the game so yeah first first loss for
Bobby Fischer and a second victory is so
far in their in their encounters for
bent Larsen wonderfully informant
Larsson and after after two draws now
Fischer loses the game so this really
really puts you know a nice halt to his
winning streak so it will definitely be
nice to see how how Fischer will recover
from this this is a as I said a very
nice game a very nice revenge by bent
Larsen in the Sicilian as I did mention
that 1958 victory by Bobby Fischer I
will put a link to that game in the
description below if you just want to
check it out but this will be officially
the last game bent Larsen ever wins
against Bobby Fischer as you all know
how their encounter in the candidates
went those very nice six games if you
don't we'll get to that part you know
don't worry I would like to thank uh
Neil Miller for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here both of them will
be games from the palm of American tours
normal tournament of of 1970 once again
I do hope you're enjoying the this
coverage of the series so far I think
over watching and I will see you soon
with another interesting video